aprendamos a multiplicar a multiplicar m
lt r a multiplicar y el mejor camino que
yo considero para poder aprenderlo es
realizando varios ejemplos y vamos a
tratar de hacer bastantes para a partir
de estos ve a lo que me refiero en
nuestro primer ejemplo digamos que
tenemos dos por tres y tú me podrás
decir yo sé cuánto es dos más tres y dos
más tres es igual a cinco de igual forma
si necesitas recordar un poco como
realizábamos esto digamos que por aquí
tenemos dos cerezas que tenemos dos
cerezas y luego tenemos por acá tres
alzamora las tres alas a moras y si
sumamos en total cuánta fruta tenemos
tenemos dos cerezas más tres alza moras
en total tenemos cinco pequeñas frutas
en total tenemos cinco pequeñas frutas o
también podemos realizarlo a través de
una recta numérica digamos que tenemos
nuestra recta numérica por aquí y vamos
a tener por aquí el 0 1
23 luego por aquí el 4 y finalmente el 5
y digamos que nos situamos primeramente
en el número 2 estamos en el 0 y tenemos
luego 2 unidades si a las 2 unidades que
tenemos por aquí le restamos tres
unidades más vamos a situarnos ahora en
el número 5 y veamos que sea de la
siguiente forma nos movemos 3 unidades 2
3 y llegamos al número 5 y esa es la
forma de realizar esta pequeña operación
y entonces cuánto es 2 por 3 una forma
fácil de pensar en la multiplicación al
producto de algo es un simple camino de
hacer sumas una y otra vez esto
significa que es un poco truculento pues
no vas a sumar dos más tres sino más
bien sumar tías hay diferentes formas de
verlo podría sumar dos veces el número
tres o tres veces el número dos
dependiendo de cómo tú lo quieras ver
esto significaría al decir que vamos a
sumar tres veces dos sería dos más
22 y esta suma es igual a 6 y te podrás
preguntar dónde queda nuestro número 3 y
pues tenemos 3 veces el número 2 como
cuando teníamos por acá las zarzamoras
ahora tenemos tres números dos entonces
al realizar esa suma
tenemos dos más dos más dos tres veces
que es lo mismo que decir que tenemos
dos por tres y dicho resultado nos va a
dar el número seis así que entonces
cuánto es dos por tres pues simplemente
tomamos el número dos y lo sumamos a sí
mismo tres veces por lo que dos más dos
es cuatro más dos es igual a seis ahora
este no es el único camino para
resolverlo pues hay otra forma de
poderlo pensar y podríamos decirlo ahora
que sumaríamos dos veces el número tres
como lo verás a continuación dice que
esto podría convertirse en algo un poco
confuso pero es muy práctico de hacerlo
para que todo tenga sentido por lo que
este enunciado que acabamos poner por
aquí
2 x 3 también puede ser descrito como
escribiendo dos veces el número tres y
aquí queda nuestro número 2 dos veces el
número tres es como cuando teníamos las
cerezas teníamos dos cerezas era una
cereza más otras esa teníamos dos esas
pero ahora vamos a tener dos número tres
y vamos a realizar dicha suma en este
escenario lo que nos está diciendo es
que vamos a sumar dos veces el número
tres a sí mismo pero lo interesante es
independientemente del camino con el que
tú lo interpretes podemos hacer esta
suma poniendo tres veces el número dos o
bien que nos da el resultado el número
seis
o bien escribiéndolo como acá abajo
sumando dos veces el número tres y nos
tiene que dar el mismo resultado pues
cuánto es tres más tres
esto también es igual a seis cierto y
quizás o muy probablemente esta es la
primera ocasión con la que te presentan
las multiplicaciones de una
tan limpia o tan desarrollado pero bueno
de cualquier forma el camino que decidas
tomar debe llevarte al mismo resultado
como lo vimos en este ejemplo en ambos
caminos llegamos al número 6 pues dos
personas pueden tener un mismo tipo de
visualización tan larga como quieran
para realizar algún tipo de problema o
dos diferentes problemas pero que vengan
con el mismo resultado y quizás ahora
podrías preguntarte bueno y cómo para
qué es útil hace este tipo de
multiplicaciones pues es demasiado útil
en algunas ocasiones no simplifica
demasiado los conteos así que digamos
que tenemos vamos a empezar de la
siguiente forma vamos a empezar con un
nuevo ejemplo siguiendo la analogía
anterior y quizás mi palabra analogía no
es muy común pero qué quiere decir que
me voy a referir a algo para realizar
una nueva cosa pero bueno como sea
digamos que nuestra fruta ahora son
limones y que tenemos tres limones por
cada
y ahora si me preguntaras cuántos
limones hay por aquí y empezáramos a
contar empezaríamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 limones tenemos por aquí y si te
das cuenta fue un tanto tardado estar
contando limón por limón así que hay
formas más fáciles y sencillas de
realizar este conteo podemos comenzar
observando cuántos limones hay en este
renglón por renglón me refiero al que va
de un lado a otro bueno espero que sepas
que es un renglón esto es un renglón y
en este renglón tenemos tres limones
entonces son tres limones y la siguiente
pregunta sería y cuántos renglones
tenemos en total y bien pues ya
señalamos nuestro primer renglón que fue
este vamos a señalarlo de un color
diferente nuestro segundo renglón tercer
renglón y cuarto renglón entonces
tenemos tres limones
cada uno de nuestros cuatro renglones en
realidad espero no confundirte creo que
se puede disfrutar demasiado todo esto y
entonces si tenemos cuatro renglones
serían cuatro por tres limones y esto
debería ser igual al número de limones
que tenemos en total tendría que ser
igual a 12 y bien solo por hacer este
problema con la misma mecánica que
hicimos el anterior entonces diremos que
4 por 3 literalmente cuando decimos esto
es que hay que visualizar que tenemos 34
veces tenemos el número 34 veces que
sería tres más tres más 33 y con esto
pues 3 + 3 es igual a 6 más 39 más 3 es
12 y aprendimos por acá arriba en esta
parte de nuestro vídeo que se interpreta
como 3 veces 4 por un lado y por otro
como cuatro veces 3 a lo que a ti se te
haga más sencillo
más útil dependiendo de lo que a ti te
convenga pero bueno de hecho es una
especie de propiedad de la
multiplicación entonces esto también
puede ser reescrito como tres veces el
número cuatro tres veces el número
cuatro y dicha suma nos daría 4 4 es
igual a 8 más 4 es igual a 12 y bien en
otras partes podemos decir que es 3 por
4 pero hay personas que quizás durante
su formación escolar o en algún otro
lado les dijeron que también es 3 veces
4 o 4 veces 3 y dicha anotación no forma
de decirlo a veces resulta ser más
intuitiva y quizás no la primera vez que
lo escuchas pero es un poco más sencillo
que te imagines cómo se escribe cuatro
veces el número tres o tres veces el
número cuatro cuatro veces el número
tres lo tendríamos por aquí y sería
escribirlo como cuatro veces el número
tres que vamos a ponerlo de nuestro lado
izquierdo
cuatro veces tres o bien si alguien te
dice tres veces el número cuatro también
resulta un tanto más intuitivo
escucharlo de esta forma y poderlo
reescribir y lo escribíamos también por
aquí abajo
tres veces el número cuatro
tres veces el número cuatro y ambos
cuando los sumas nos da el resultado del
número 12 3 por 4 es igual a 12 y bien
ahora quizás esté diciendo wow está
padre lo que nos han enseñado en cannes
es un tanto interesante saber este truco
para poderlo aplicar en las
multiplicaciones y no solamente para
nuestro ejemplo de los limones y para
poder realizar este problema también te
puede funcionar para algunos otros
problemas en las que las cantidades
quizás sean muchísimo más grandes que en
lugar de tener tres limones en este
renglón qué pasaría si tuvieras en lugar
de tres limones 100 limones no te ibas a
poner a contarlo uno por uno no
acabarías entonces como eso te tomaría
demasiado tiempo aquí podríamos aplicar
nuestro nuevo truco que se ha vuelto
bastante útil ahora otro truco que
resulta ser bastante interesante y me
hace recordar a mi hermana tratando de
demostrar que era mucho más astuto
y yo puedas me encontraba en el kinder y
ella se encontraba en tercer grado y
entonces le gustaba preguntarme oye
cuánto estrés por uno y yo le contestaba
a lo siguiente porque mi cerebro decía
pues sí tres más uno es igual a cuatro
entonces yo creía que tres por uno debía
ser igual a cuatro y entonces yo le
contestaba así y ella me decía no tres
por uno es igual a tres y a mí no me
cabía en la cabeza cómo era posible que
un número x otro fuera igual a el mismo
pero a qué nos referimos a tres por uno
porque es igual a el mismo pues es como
si tuviéramos tres veces uno tres veces
uno es la suma de estos tres 12 entonces
nos da igual a 3 que es lo mismo que
poner una vez nuestro número 3 que es
como lo acabamos de colocar aquí abajo y
ambos nos dan el mismo resultado y
entonces también podrías decir que 100
por 1 va a ser igual a 100 o bien qué
c 1 x 39 pues también va a ser igual a
39 y bueno creo que ahora que ya estamos
bastante familiarizados con este nuevo
número con nuestro número 1 y que
también marca una propiedad interesante
podríamos ver ahora qué pasaría si
hacemos una multiplicación pero
multiplicando por 0 bueno primero
recordando cuánto era 3 + 0 y esto era
igual a 3 pues era como no estarle
sumando algo al número 3
pues si tengo 3 manzanas y luego te 20
manzanas pues sólo tendrías 3 manzanas
en total y ahora cambiando un poco
utilizamos el número 4 entonces qué
pasaría o cuánto nos va a dar cuatro por
cero pues bien podemos reescribirlo como
cuatro veces nuestro número cero que a
sumar los 0 + 0 + 0 +0 nos va a dar
igual a 0 o bien también podríamos
reescribirlo como 0 veces 4 pero cómo
vamos a poder
y al 40 veces solo no escribimos nada
cierto pues si escribiéramos algo
tendríamos ahí algo y el ser 0 veces el
número 4 tendríamos que dejar
simplemente ese espacio en negro que
tenemos arriba tenemos cuatro veces el
cero y abajo tenemos nada que es cero
veces nuestro número cuatro y entonces
simplemente dejamos nuestro espacio ahí
y como podrás darte cuenta es otra cosa
divertida de multiplicar por cero algún
número podríamos escribir un número
enorme como 5 millones 493 mil 692 por 0
y esta multiplicación simplemente nos va
a dar igual a 0 o también podría decir 0
x no sé tal vez 17 y dicha operación
multiplicación también te va a dar 0 y
bueno espero te haya sido interesante